à l'autre bout de la région baptiste
notre prof d'histoire est lui aussi dans
le brouillard de l'hiver je suis ce
matin à loches au coeur de la cité
royale
une cité qu'on a tendance à oublier et
pourtant qu'à une histoire passionnante
et du coup on nous la raconter je vais
rencontrer jean françois jean-françois
tulle et le directeur de la cité royale
jean-françois bonjour bâtisse bonjour
merci
alors parlez moi peut-être cette cité
royale est bien resté royal à se caser
d'être une cité qui est désigné par le
roi comme un lieu de résidence un lieu
de sûreté dont callas label royal si
j'ose dire
la cité royale de loches est un monument
unique qui couvre mille ans d'histoire
bâti sur les bords de l'indre
elle est défendue au sud par un donjon
de 36 mètres de haut construit au 10ème
siècle qui est considéré aujourd'hui
comme l'un des mieux conservés de
l'époque romane en europe et au nord se
situe le logis une résidence royale
construite à la fin du 14e siècle
au fil du temps elle a accueilli des
plus grands personnages de l'histoire
parmi lesquels charles cette jeanne
d'arc
agnès sorel charles un 8 louis xii ou
encore anne de bretagne demeurer dans un
état de préservation exceptionnelles
ces deux kilomètres de remparts protège
encore la grande cour carrée du château
c'est un lieu qui a été marquée manière
évidente par la gare de santons qui est
une période de essentiel où finalement
le roi de france est en reconquête de
son territoire qui est occupée par
l'angleterre il ne veut pas aller à
paris voilà c'est charles vii qui fait
de loches sa résidence principale au
xvème siècle quand le nord de la loire
est occupée par les anglais pour lui et
loches al'avantage d'être en retrait et
surtout de pouvoir lui offrir un lieu de
résidence quasi permanente
et c'est là qu'il va ensuite posé des
actes importants pour reconquérir son
royaume dans la chambre du roi jeanne
d'arc convainc charles vii de se faire
sacrer à reims et donc c'est dans cette
salle que s'est joué le sort de la
france un certain moment parce que
charles vii sur les conseils de jeanne
d'arc a décidé de ne pas aller
reconquérir la normandie qui appartenait
à ce moment là aux anglais mais plutôt
d'aller à reims pour se faire sacrer roi
et devenir le vrai roi légitime de
france
l'autre visage emblématique de la cité
royale est une figure plus contestées
agnès sorel la favorite de charles vii
c'est sa dame de coeur et il accueille à
sa table
il accueille près de lui de manière très
fréquentée surtout dans son lit voilà et
il la reconnaît publiquement comme celle
qu'il a choisie
c'est la première fois des officiels
très influente auprès du roi la haute
noblesse accuse agnès sorel de mettre en
danger le royaume
c'est une femme qui évidemment est ce
moment magnifique mais qui est également
un bel esprit donc il ya une collation
quittera riches et qui par ailleurs
révolutionne la mode aussi bien la mode
vestimentaire que la mode capillaire
d'ailleurs qui est pas très bien vu et
donc elle elle bouleverse complètement
légitime de la cour qu est une coque a
été marquée par les épreuves gags sont
enquis concours un peu austère elle a
tellement marqué la cité de son
empreinte qu'aujourd'hui une tour porte
son nom
[Musique]